sie wollten noch einmal an den ort in
hanau wo vor einem jahr kann gültekin
erschossen wurde ihr bruder und onkel da
wo diese zwei steckdosen sind laut
meinem bruder den ganzen globus der
ganzen menschen
das haben wir erst mal aber fangen mich
realisiert was eigentlich passiert ist
kurz nach dem attentat am 19 22 01 20
einen steten und mert gültekin an den
tatort zu dem zeitpunkt hat der täter
tobias er bereits gezielt neun menschen
getötet
alle mit migrationsgeschichte dann
erschießt er seine mutter und sich
selbst
der 37-jährige will kann war eines der
opfer
seit dieser nacht ist für die gültig ins
nichts mehr wie es war
die mutter kommt ohne medikamente nicht
mehr zurecht der vater er liegt kurz
nach dem tod seines sohnes seinem
krebsleiden bruder ted ihn und sein sohn
sind traumatisiert und können nicht mehr
arbeiten begann war das fundament um
zeit seitdem unsere fundament nicht mehr
da ist sind wir nur noch am backen
jede wand wackelt moment ahnt und seit
einem jahr gibt keine einzige nacht wo
ich sag ich bin mal durchgeschlafen kann
es nicht mehr schlafen meint gerade
nachts wenn dunkles wenn du deinen kopf
an dem kissen linz kommen dann die
fragen die dich richtig fressen
die familie zieht um weil die alte
wohnung zu nahe am tatort ist und sie es
dort nicht mehr aushalten
vater und sohn teilen sich seitdem ein
zimmer damit nicht klar
alte wohnung nachließ ungetrübten habe
ich das bett gesehen war komplett und
deswegen das ist sehr wichtig dass wir
zusammen
denn damit zu lassen
zur trauer mischt sich aber auch immer
mehr wut seit 1 jahr schreiben wir
schneiden wir schreiben wir uns bis
heute kein einziges erfolgserlebnis dass
wir sagen weißt du ja das haben wir
wenigstens geschafft nur ins leere nur
ins level nur ins leere und diese
politiker tun uns jedes mal angucken uns
alles den angehörigen reicht das nicht
sie haben zusammen mit unterstützern die
initiative neunzehnter februar gegründet
und fordern dass die behörden
verantwortung übernehmen warum hatte der
täter einen waffenschein obwohl er
psychisch krank war oder warum war der
notruf der polizei in der tatnacht
anscheinend nicht ausreichend besetzt
weder das hessische innenministerium
noch die hanauer polizei sind zu einem
interview bereit
doch die deutsche polizeigewerkschaft
äußert sich verantwortung für die
polizei in dem sinne dass sie an der
einen oder anderen stelle das und das
hätte tun können und dann wäre es
verhindert worden die sich in der tat
nicht
insofern ist es sehr wohlfeil hinterher
zu sagen was die polizei alles hätte
vorher wissen müssen tekin gültekin
fühlt sich in deutschland nicht mehr
sicher der türkischstämmige hanauer hat
angst wenn er nachts unterwegs ist oder
wenn sein sohn zu spät nach hause kommt
denn rechtsextreme attentate nehmen
immer weiter zu
davor warnen auch expertinnen und
experten
wir brauchen sehr deutlich ein stark
prävention gegen rechtsextremismus dh
die behandlung des themas muss früh
anfangen wir müssen vorbeugend handeln
wir müssen sozusagen vor die lage kommen
nicht erst dann uns immer etwas
ausdenken was wir tun können
bei der strafverfolgung bei der
sicherheitsarbeit nach dem etwas
passiert ist rechtsextreme einstellungen
sind vorher da und sie motivieren
menschen dann sich organisationen
anzuschließen
gültekin fordert solidarisch zu sein und
wachsamer er hat mir meine leben
beginnen
er hat mir alles meine
alles weggenommen wählen habe ich getan
und deswegen seit einem jahr kämpfen wir
mit familien für gerechtigkeit und
aufklärung